- I think that's so inspiring.
I know your whole story,
and I know and everybody else doesn't.
So, talk everybody through it,
let's talk about your stroke,
like when that happened.
- So I'm legally obligated to explain,
I'm not a doctor,
I've just played one on T.V.
(laughing)
But my specific stroke happened,
it's very glamorous.
I was at a film festival in Florida
at a premier of a movie I'd just done.
And after winning best supporting actor,
thanks, I'ma brag,
(laughing)
for those.
Then I was in the men's
room at the Tampa Airport.
And I just suddenly,
next thing I know I was on the floor.
- Like out of no where?
- Out of no where.
I had a bottled water,
I was tryin' to screw the cap back on.
Until my left hand wasn't working.
So, I was like, ah, it's weird.
It is cause I? Ah, that's not.
And then my leg, my left
leg went out from under me.
- That is crazy.
Like out of no where?
- Out of no where.
I'd had a really bad
headache the night before,
which I've now learned
that if you've ever had the
worst headache in your life,
you go to the emergency room.
- But no one would know that
'cause people get migraines all the time.
- Yeah, so you never know.
- Yeah.
- But somehow these gentlemen
in the men's room decided
I wasn't either drunk or on drugs.
And either dragged or
Thank you, thank you guys whoever you are.
(chuckles)
And they either carried me
or dragged me out of the bathroom.
Put me in the waiting area
on a bench kind of like
this with no arm here.
So I kept sliding out this
'cause I was about to get on
a plane to fly back to L.A.
But I knew my flight was over there,
so I kept tryin' to get
up and walk that way
and my leg just kept going out.
- Wow.
- So I've probably fell like
12 times in the airport.
- That's incredibly scary.
- It was pretty freaky.
- Just to not know
what's happening.
That would scare me to death.
I don't know how you did that.
But the most amazing
part was actually you.
There ended being a role in This Is Us,
that they based off of your
real life experience, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So Dan Fogelman, who's
the creator of that show,
also created another T.V.
show called Galavant.
And he would tabs on me
and my recovery process.
And texted me one day, and is like,
"I think I got somethin' ya."
"I'm thinking about writing a guy"
"who's deep in recovery from a stroke."
- Yeah.
- And I was like, "Sign me up man."
- And this is while you
were going through recovery,
learning to walk
and all of that again, right?
- Exactly.
- That's kinda cool
'cause it was kinda like a
light at the end of the tunnel.
Like, "Man, okay, I got this project."
- It was a huge impetus to
learn how to walk again.
- Wow, I can image that.
- You know, and a lot of
people think about strokes,
they think of old people.
- It can happen to anyone.
No, no, no, yeah.
- So I was 48 when it happened.
- Yeah.
- Best shape in my life.
Like low cholesterol,
low blood pressure.
Usually, is one of these
out of the blue things,
like, you just never know.
- Yeah.
So, you've been,
you've had this craft you're whole life
and you had to kinda relearn to do things.
What was your first back like?
- Was actually the
technical first day back
was on Psych: The Movie 2.
- Oh yeah.
- Lassie Come Home.
- Yeah.
(claps)
- Don't applaud.
(laughing)
I was really just odd
get back to on set
where I've been this thing my entire life
and it's like muscle memory.
And suddenly these muscles are gone.
- Yeah.
- So I quickly learned that
I couldn't memorize the lines
as quick as I did.
- So was it harder then, going back?
Or was is kind of fun and exciting
because it's, you know this so well?
- Yeah.
- Deep in you, innately.
- In fact on Psych,
such an amazing group of people,
my cast and producers.
They rewrote the movie
to really mirror much like this
as of what's going on with me physically.
- Yeah.
- So Lassie gets, spoiler alert, shock,
Shawn has a stroke on the operating table.
- Wow.
- So the whole is me in recovery.